there's so many things that have
bipartisan support already
and the most important thing is i think
there is a general understanding
among all republicans that we need to do
something
we don't have time to waste here and
it's something
that we believe could pass our chamber
and in the house
all right that was a sign of things to
come when i had a chance to speak with
both prominent democratic senators and
republican senators as well as a number
of
congressmen and women both parties who
are open to a 900 billion dollar
stimulus measure
that would go a long way toward
providing emergency relief
right now before the biden
administration takes office on january
20th let's get a fair and balanced read
on how likely that is with
representative jesse johnson republican
from south dakota
and we've got representative dean
phillips democrat from minnesota
gentlemen
welcome to both of you and thank you for
taking the time
um congressman uh phillips if i can
begin with you
this idea that there's bipartisan
support for this
where is the bipartisan support in other
words what are the features that you
agree
should should be enacted right now
rather than wait till
next year when when when joe biden takes
over
well neil if you take a look at the
march to common ground plan that my
friend and colleague dusty johnson who's
on right now with me
i helped co-lead and develop some a
couple months ago
if you look at the new bipartisan
bicameral plan that we worked with
senators on
just introduced a few days ago you'll
see that there's a lot of agreement
so to answer your question directly i
think we've made great progress
and look at nobody's going to get
everything they want and to those who
have lost faith in government i tell you
the antidote is the problem solvers
caucus and
democrats and republicans working
together to find common ground and
that's exactly what we did and now it's
up to some others in the house and
senate and i have some confidence we're
going to get it done
no i'm very impressed with the problem
solvers caucus because you try to put
politics aside and at least find some
common ground it looks like enough has
been found here that you have
so uh congressman johnson to you on that
um
do you think there is enough common
ground that this will pass
i absolutely think it's going to pass it
needs to pass
the reality is 778 000 americans filed
for unemployment for the first time last
week
and we had 10 000 of our countrymen die
and i think neil you see
that every hour that goes by another
prominent legislative leader steps up
and adds their voice to ours frankly
this thing looked dead a week ago
but since we made our announcement on
tuesday all of the momentum
is headed toward passage
joe biden has offered some insight in
his thinking on this and i think
congressman phillips what he was saying
is
he'd like to see that 1200 stimulus
check that that was obviously
very popular the initial pandemic relief
plan
uh i don't believe it's part of this one
yet
uh do you think it will be you know neil
time will tell of course the president
uh was very much in favor of direct
stimulus checks in the past
you know i believe that consumption is
the engine of the economy and money in
people's pockets
is the fuel and in times like these i do
believe that sending money to people
directly who are struggling the most
is a net benefit to the economy actually
will cost less now than it will down the
road so i am in favor of it
uh we weren't able to achieve everything
that everybody wanted in the current
framework but i'm still hopeful that
that could
if it finds bipartisan support could be
achieved because i certainly favor it
um congressman johnson i talked to your
republican counterpart in the senate
chuck grassley
who was saying um you know he's open to
this he's open to a lot of it but don't
go
crazy on on you know another effort that
would be just as expensive and not more
expensive let's see how this goes
are you in that camp that you're you're
open to maybe this
but but no more multi-trillion dollar
relief down the road
well i mean there are lots of voices
that want to add more to this package
but the reality is
this is the number that can get done i
think if you make the package a lot
larger you lose a ton of republicans if
you make it a lot smaller you lose a ton
of democrats
if politics is the art of the possible
and it is
this is the right package and i voted
against uh you know big
three trillion dollar packages and two
trillion dollar packages
packages that the speaker has put on the
floor in the past this
is the thing that can get done this is
the deal that can
bring some housing and nutrition and
unemployment
and paycheck protection relief to the
american people let's get this thing
done
frankly neil i can't believe it wasn't
done two or three months ago
i mean if democrats like dean phillips
and republicans like dusty johnson
who are rank and file members can come
to agreement on this
why in the world can our leadership not
do it
i mean i just feel like they've let
politics get in the way let's get this
thing done and 908
is the right number it's higher than i
want but it's the one that can get done
all right we'll watch very closely
gentlemen i want to thank you both i
hope spring's eternal for bipartisan
support
it is possible with guys of you out
there so uh
we'll see what happens in in the weeks
to come